I thought tonight we would return to the
puzzles I know a lot of people they
really like the other strategical puzzle
episodes so I thought yeah we'll give do
a little more puzzles those are always
fun I picked out three hopefully we have
time to go over all of them tonight and
tonight's theme is going to be peace
play which can mean a lot of things so
peace play can mean maneuvering it can
mean improving your worst place peace it
can mean you know restricting your
opponent's plans with your pieces so it
can mean sort of a lot of things I just
like to pick out sort of puzzles that
are strategic in nature rather than
tactical puzzles and the one big problem
with this I guess for in a certain sense
is when you do a tactic of course
there's okay a big checkmate or there's
some obvious you win material and you
get this satisfaction that you did
indeed definitely pick the very best
move and a lot of the moves tonight
might if you ask a computer be
relatively the same or they you know it
the evaluation stays relatively the same
but yet there's all sorts of little
things that at least when two humans are
playing do make a big difference so
we'll see a lot of positions tonight
where even though the human the computer
says zero zero zero it'll be one side is
just obviously better or worse and at
our human mortal level that's where
games are really wanted lost somebody
gets a better position and then it
becomes harder and harder to play the
side that is losing or on the the wrong
side of equality so I'm gonna throw it
over to the board right now and our
first puzzle this is a Ivan Sokolov
versus drazi native I'm not gonna
pronounce any names right cuz I never do
but uh in this position here so it's
white to move Lex last move with King to
c7 and I do want to give the audience a
little bit of time here some people were
here early I've already had some time
but at home for all these puzzles you do
want to pause because the people here
they're gonna get five minutes to think
about it
you really do want to pause your video
to get the same effect as the live
audience here or more you can take as
much time as you want at home okay it's
wait to move and and before we we talk
about the position we'll give you guys a
chance and then hopefully we can assess
this position and talk about what's
going on and see if we can come up with
the moves that they came up with in the
game and again it's and sort of its its
piece play so we do want to kind of
think of our piecing the general theme
is going to be take a piece maybe your
worst place piece or maybe a piece
that's just not on the dream Square to
be a little bit better and find a better
Square for a night find a great outpost
for a bishop find a nice diagonal you
know for Brooks find some open files
that's sort of a deal so I think did you
have your hand up Knight - D - okay
where are you going you want to get to a
four you want to get to be five okay and
so you're doing this okay you say yes
I've I just wait and you're you're going
here yeah I probably just bring my stuff
in and yeah what do you hear I can push
here alright yeah I think over the last
few moves blacks position has improved a
lot more than the whites so it's a bit
slow and it you know it is a square
where it's not really a permanent square
if you could just jump there right now
and you know with a big check then maybe
would be a decent move yeah
Bishop d3 okay and do you have a any big
idea after I'll just make some move okay
and you're gonna put the bishop on this
diagonal like I say alright so I know
what you want to do so I guess I'll stop
you and India with a lot of these I mean
there's probably a lot of moves that
okay don't really again they don't like
like there's necessarily one right or
wrong move but I'm not sure that this is
necessarily the right square for the
bishop especially if I don't ever let
you go to e4 but I mean I don't think
that's that's bad at all either so II -
is better you think okay and I'll just
I'll just keep doing nothing just to see
what you're what you're up to do you
have any plans from here and I guess to
thinking a little bit in a little bit
different way about the position we do
kind of want to see we're looking at our
pieces we're trying to see you know
who's looking good
who's not looking good okay you could be
a little bit better you're you're decent
you have some some potential that pieces
okay this piece is pretty nice I'm this
guy we're looking at some stuff he's
probably not the best this bishop you
know probably not the best I got to find
some better squares and I'm gonna give
it the answer away so again at home you
can pause if you need more time but in
the game white chose the move if you let
me f5
deciding that this is the best diagonal
for the bishop and if you remember - so
this was blacks last move
so okay it makes sense to take this
bishop that isn't doing a whole lot you
know I don't need to really watch the d4
square cuz I have my pawn here well I
want to get onto this diagonal and
blacks all that and stop them in the
game the move g5 was played also
possible is a move like 'if I've
so I think both of these moves should be
considered and just to give you an
example of what might happen here we can
take and toss this check in trying to
provoke the pawn forward and in a
position like this well maybe I you know
now that I provoked your pawn forward
maybe I got the d5 square and maybe I
just have the long-term plan of getting
my knight to the d5 square so something
like this also was possible
so that's perhaps why in the game the
opponent chose g5 okay so they he's not
letting you go to that diagonal so again
we got a we got to rethink this and this
is the move that I quite liked about
this game this next move here the first
move yeah I mean there's a whole bunch
of plans that are perhaps perfectly fine
for white to try but I do like this move
here so again I'll give you guys a
little bit of time you can pause at home
wait actually did find a way to get back
on that diagonal so black stopped him
but he didn't say you know okay I guess
I didn't get it darn and they played
some other random move he was he was
assistant he wanted to get to that
diagonal so he found the way we shut
that door in the back because it's it's
terrifying out there scary world people
it's dark
it's dark it gets dark early now so in
the game this should G one so he's
really insisting on getting onto that
diagonal
okay so f6 he's trying to shore up some
of the dark squares he's trying to get a
grip on the e5 he anticipates White's
next move and he plays the move e5 which
is a temporary pawn sacrifice because we
can take on the Sun the alternative is
my D to e5 but this isn't super
appealing when you see that we can take
once and drop our rook in and we're
probably gonna win upon this and also
we're also threatening to take with the
rook so we're threatening to capture two
different ways
so for that reason he temporarily gave
up upon with the idea that now he's
blockaded and my next move is Bishop
takes c6 so I decided well if you really
want that pawn you're gonna have to work
for it you can go get it so he kind of
finds an annoying way for his opponent
to have to go get the pawn okay so I
have to go pick it up with my rook and
now the pawn structure has sort of
changed on the Queen side so again we're
gonna see white just get his pieces into
the games you'll notice some you know
files are open / half open over on the
Queen side stuff has opened up there a
little bit and so now I just move okay
the next two moves are not brilliant
you're not gonna be blown off the board
but as these simple moves that sometimes
people struggle to find in their own
games so I guess I'll just ask what you
guys would what do you hear what's your
next couple of moves the plan just to
improve your pieces get pieces that
aren't doing stuff into the game
all right rook d5 and what you're
worried about this move okay yeah I was
just I was gonna take the pawn first I
guess
and yeah so it's it could be a good
square but now it's what these pawns
gone I guess it's not a very permanent
square is it because you were right yep
Bishop e6 might come at some point soon
here so it's just a simple move I mean
watch I guess what's the most natural
move if you develop your pieces Bishop
e2 all right he took it and he just
brings another piece into the game rook
f1 so yeah now that there's stuff going
on over here we're thinking about taking
the knight and the rope can start to
infiltrate somewhere along the F file
that's exactly what happened so he took
and INGOs the rook and the computer here
says zero zero zero and black played
this move you know brought his rook from
one bad square to another so in general
if black has to play a move like this I
mean know whatever the computer really
says it's it's kind of obvious that
white is actually better here just
because it's there's so many targets the
white is looking at so you'd really
rather be white here okay all of my
pieces are suddenly good this this guy's
great this guy's great this this guy's
got some pressure this guy he might have
a future and so this also is important
too so this next move is a really nice
one so I'll let you guys try to figure
it out
you know so it's good we got all these
nice targets but how are we gonna keep
improving our position can we find even
more squares for some of our pieces here
and this is really what I want to do too
because you're you got pressure here I
don't want my rook here all day
babysitting this pawn so my next move if
you let me I'm gonna play the move h5
yeah
Bishop h5 yeah so this is an excellent
move the bishop comes to a better Square
perhaps in the future we can Riemann ooh
ver to some square over here you know
somehow we can find a better square on
the board but also you're maintaining
this target so now the H pawn is just a
fixed target and my piece is really
active and you can sit here and watch
your own pond so a very good move and
you know this is the kind of piece play
that you you do want to be looking for
in your game okay and so now from here I
guess this will have to finish it for
this exercise because I do want to get
to the other ones well look at the
conclusion of the game I guess there's
one more interesting point it was in
this position and so here again you'll
notice that over the last couple moves
waste pieces just keep improving you
know now with you know that LightSquared
Bishop into it the attack to so now this
is just fantastic for white however the
computer is like no big deal it's equal
but black has to find an only move here
that I think is really challenging so I
did give again somebody at the club a
lot of time and they they came up with
half of the idea and they're pretty
decently high rated player so I'll give
you a chance just to see how you could
play this as black because there is one
move that can sort of save this position
for black but again this is sort of when
you get these better positions like this
it becomes really really hard as the
defender to find all of these moves
especially when they're sort of
spectacular there's an idea that you
need to understand in order to solve
this that okay it's not so apparent but
what might help too is if you think what
would white play if it was White's next
turn so we do a little prophylactic
thinking
and even when you know that it's still
kind of hard to figure this one out so
I'll give you guys a chance and okay if
it were white to move
what would White's move be in this
position
how would white continue to improve his
position age five yeah if it's whites
turn age five just solidifying his
position there the pond forever remains
a target here on h6 and obviously my
bishop is not going to get locked out of
the game so now I can you know continue
with ideas so if black plays h5 right
away I'm pretty sure the move was here
so before I don't want to take on any
tribe just yet I go here so I'm still
threatening you're H pawn but I'm not
gonna let you play g3 and kick me away
and it's hard to defend so this is the
right idea but this is not quite right
we can do even better
so even knowing the idea it's still
pretty difficult which you know so if
you have this position in the game and
you know your computers laughing haha
everything's equal it's it's not always
so true when humans are playing so this
it's very hard to find the next couple
moves here for black but along the same
lines I'll just give it away
you have the sensational move g3 okay
what's what's this all about
what's that h5 now yeah now h5 uh-huh so
you can't take obviously because it's
it--there's this I lined up your bishops
so if your LightSquared bishop moves
away i take on g3 and if you just move
away this is the last move that you have
to find Bishop g4
and black has consolidated and your
computer will defend this perfectly to a
draw but not so easy at all when you're
playing in an actual game and just going
back just to show the the beginning of
this puzzle one more time it came from
white just identifying where he wanted
to improve his pieces he said well just
thinking about this bishop and I'm just
thinking what diagonal do I want him on
I want him on the same diagonal as my
opponent's king and that's from there
all sorts of good stuff kept happening
and he had the same idea so Bishop g1
was an excellent move and from there I
just kind of played itself he just sort
of naturally got his pieces in and they
he just slowly outplayed his opponent
all right okay let's look at that one
more here let's see okay
so blacks last move was f6 and this is
the sort of pawn structure you can get
in positions where the black Queen goes
to b6 and trades for a queen on b3 and
the a pawn took back and there's sort of
well-known ideas in this type of
position all the time what is trying to
think about tactically making a move
like b5 work in this type of position so
that's definitely a feature and there is
a maneuver here that white has so
thinking about the pieces there's one
way he can really increase the pressure
on the Queen side but I'll I'll give it
to you guys and see what you guys come
up with but yeah if you know this this
type of position that's something that
that comes actually quite naturally
but yeah so at home you might want to
pause what Claudio hit on it you
maneuver the night over to a5 which
creates lots of pressure here on the
Queen side so that's the maneuver and I
do like kind of what happened in this
game it it got kind of tactical pretty
fast which is what happens when you get
your pieces to the most active squares
well the tactics normally are gonna
favor you so here the move e5 was played
which is a mistake but the positions
already quite difficult relatively best
would have been to passively defend the
Queen side I mean obviously why it is
much better here so you can see my black
wouldn't want to defend like this
forever
so okay he's going for counter play e5
95
and yeah this is this is quite bad in
the game
rook c7 which doesn't work as well see
you can also put the rook on b8 this
also doesn't quite work but again I kind
of like this it's it's sort of difficult
I think to find the absolute strongest
move here for white so this is gonna be
the real task for this puzzle is sort of
figuring out what white should do well
you got this great position black's
pieces are really tied down on the Queen
side obviously you're looking for all
sorts of different sacrifices that might
work
we'll see can we find the absolute
strongest move here for white
and there's at least two moves that win
pretty convincingly yeah
I don't think this quite works but but
maybe do you have an idea here
okay what was the idea because they
might work in other variations okay
right a very interesting idea right so
if I take here then you can throw this
in but then you realized I can take here
okay mm-hmm so yeah a very interesting
idea and these are this is indeed the
kind of sacrifice that you are looking
for in this structure so after having
maneuvered our piece over to this very
active square we are looking for the
move b5 at all times but here
unfortunately it just doesn't quite work
bishop f1 which is in general a better
Square for the bishop but I mean let me
just let me just see what your point is
let me just pass for a second same thing
you want to play b5 is that your point
okay
any problem yeah so this is actually in
a lot of lines it might be a better
diagonal so I'm seeing that you guys
noticed that this is probably not the
best diagonal for the bishop so you know
a very common way what it's not any good
diagonal is to obviously go to try to
find a better diagonal for the bishop
there's also another way that he can
stay on the diagonal and that is to just
continue to attack the the wall that
you're staring at
so efore is it's surprisingly the
strongest move in this position and yeah
the tension really favors white because
now we're taking here with everything
and as white we're a lot that are
prepared for the center to just blow
wide open because then this bishop is
also going to be adding pressure down
this diagonal so it doesn't matter
whichever way you take I don't want to
take either way but you know if you take
something like this then you're just
you're bringing my pieces into the game
and now I might go to e6 this is it's
gonna really fall apart here for black
so move like efore in such a position is
another way to get the bishop that is
staring at the wall into the game
another surprising move there's also a
tactical continuation that white can do
that's perhaps more spectacular it's too
bad it's it's slightly inferior you can
actually take here on b7 a very
surprising sacrifice and if they take
you have to find the next move so if you
gave up your knight you better have seen
this next move which is okay it's quite
amazing so b5 yeah look at that so if we
take this way we're gonna run into a
fork this pawn is pinned
so perhaps relatively best might be to
sacrifice the exchange which is okay
which is perfectly fine for us because
we're gonna take this and okay now we
got this passer here so that's fine for
us we're happy with that
um what if I play here I think I think
it might be difficult to find the right
continuation here is white so again
that's and so here we can see so the
tactics are really related to piece play
you get your pieces to all the great
squares and then there's gonna be all
these these tactics that are gonna favor
you and again I think there's there's
more than one move here but like a four
I think that's probably super strong
here as well you can even take this and
if they take back you can take on d5 and
this is gonna be very good for white so
that's so there's all these sacrifices
that can occur and they happen because
well we got all of our pieces aiming at
your weaknesses here in the game rook to
c7 which is even worse and again efore
is super strong in this position but in
the game a very typical sacrifice b5 and
after black took
there's just one more move here to find
I'm looking at you it works here exactly
so he took here and black resigned if
you take the night I take on a eight and
if you take if you take here I take oh I
can't click the thing yeah so here here
and yeah if here you toss in this check
and wherever the King goes where the
King goes you take this and okay we're
all over d5 okay
and so for that reason black already
resigned which is a little bit early but
you are you are losing in this position
so fantastic so I just wanted to show
that just to illustrate just like we've
never seen this kinds of type of
position before this is a very very
common maneuver they weak in the dark
squares see you maneuver your knight to
a dark square and then you get all sorts
of potential to sacrifice your pieces
okay one more saving the best for last
so this is the game Michael Prugh second
versus Wolf's game omen from
indecipherable year but I know Jason
really needs to know there's 2004 I will
blow the stuff again for the audience
okay so in this position it's white to
move and this is a King's Indian pawn
structure and you'll realize this is a
very closed position so often in the
Kings Indian Black gets a big attack on
the Kings side but now with the Kings
side closed like this there's no
meaningful breaks the black will ever
achieve over there
f5 should probably never work because we
got everything that can take it so all
of the action is going to be on the
Queen side in this position so you can
kind of tell then it's white that has a
little bit more space and well I'll give
you guys a little bit of time to to
think about what you would play in this
position but obviously we need to sort
of get our pieces to the Queen side tidy
up
position and there's a couple moves that
I think we're very very nice and what I
like about this puzzle too is that
they're all corrective actually like the
computer moves it's not like
everything's zero zero zero I think
white actually did play the best moves
at least for as long as we're gonna look
at the puzzle it was like a 90 move game
though and there was like a lot of
mistakes so the thing about this game so
we won't watch the whole thing is white
played brilliantly for the next few
moves got a good position and then it
was like drawing then White was losing
and then white one it's a lots of
mistakes were made in this game but the
next couple of maneuvers the white
played were really instructive and I
think this is the best game of the bunch
so I will be quiet for a few minutes
here I'll give you guys five minutes
probably and okay at home go ahead and
pause your project videos and take as
much time as you need got it
you've an idea all right let's try do b5
okay at least if I can hit enter really
fast so people don't see the the actual
thing so now I can just if I want
totally lock it up that's up to me you
know I could play a 5 so I'm wondering
is black can I you know maybe play move
like work a 7 or just Queen b8 or
something and just I just want to play
like here that's right I want to keep
the option I think it's black here I
think I might actually start thinking
about trying to play for an advantage I
mean I think I can go here if I just
want to be boring and and draw but okay
I bet did you have an idea beyond that
or what did you think what was why did
you play the move before
mmm-hmm but I guess to who do you think
is better because if you play the move
b5 and you allow a five you're just
saying it's a draw you know so maybe if
you think you're worse that's something
that you would consider
white you have a little bit more space I
think the tension here favors you
because black never really wants to
think about taking this because whenever
we take back we're gonna have some
pressure on the a pond and stuff like
that so thank you you as white here
should be trying to increase your
advantage and you don't want to play a
move like b5 giving away the tension I
think here's is gonna favor black so
let's see if we can we can be a little
more ambitious here with white
ah very interesting idea yeah so Claudia
wants to put all of his rooks on the B
file which is exactly what happened he
chose to go to h2 first well that's the
idea that rook swings over to the B file
so yeah all these pieces in the way it's
you know it's hard to get your rook over
to the B file and that's where it needs
to be well okay so he just goes over all
the pieces and goes laterally so that's
exactly what happens okay in both
players just played a couple moves here
and now in this position this is the
real fantastic part so why now played a
fantastic maneuver thinking about all of
his pieces here and he found a way to
get some pieces to a slightly better
spot so this this is fantastic what
white chose to do here so again you want
to pause at home again I'm gonna give
you guys lots of time and I'll be really
impressed if people do come up with the
move that was chosen in the game
just give up no idea it is quite
difficult I mean so even at home if if
people do find this it's quite
impressive just to have this
misconception here so some people are
really trying and some people are
falling asleep like I'll never find it
yep so wait to move Knight to f5 hit the
Return button real quick do you do you
think this I guess in this position - so
you're offering this this trade which
animal maybe you're trying to get the e4
square like if I take back you're gonna
try get the e4 square for your night but
I guess - just looking at the Knights
which I think this might is just
superior because this guy is kind of out
of the game I don't know how he plans on
getting back into the game but I guess
even if I I mean because I don't have to
take obviously I can defend my knight or
move my knight but uh but okay but if I
did take it you're a point you were
taking this way or and you got you got a
nice yeah so maybe I don't want to take
that maybe I this one in this position
or in which position right here do I
sack for the H fun
this one you just sagging everything
I'll just keep taking it until I
understand what's going on okay tell us
how else can we give more pieces away I
don't believe it
I don't believe it it's not that so yeah
so again it's it's not like a sacrifice
or anything eventually white is gonna do
something on the queenside eventually
I'll take or eventually I'll play a four
a five and I'll open the queenside
somehow but I can be a little bit
patient I have more space I'm just kind
of sitting on you I still have time to
improve my position get it to the
maximum I want to look at every single
one of my pieces make sure every one of
them is exactly where I want them to be
and only then will I think about opening
the queenside because it's actually
quite difficult for black to be the one
that starts opening the queenside and
we'll see that in the game eventually
black got a little antsy and he's like
well you know I see that you're slowly
improving your position I'm gonna break
and it didn't work out in the game so we
will get to see that but did you have an
idea
yeah rook rook b1r okay to be one
perfectly fine most great move you know
nothing wrong with that
it wasn't chosen to the game but no no
there's nothing wrong with that which is
the thing about strategic puzzles you
know it's not it's not like so instantly
satisfying I'm sure there's a lots of
just normal improving tidying moves that
are perfectly valid so there's nothing
wrong with that at all I do like this
move so if you if you have come up with
this one and you know again a big
congrats because this is this is
fantastic and so ok so we know where
these guys are gonna go let's think
about all our pieces here we know about
these rooks we got an idea of you know
probably if they go on the B file I'm
just kind of hanging out here just to
make sure you never take because then
I'd already have a file pressure with my
rook
well my Knights fantastic fantastic you
know both my bishops could be a little
bit better which is the thing about the
closed positions you know obviously
they're gonna favor the Knights so
nobody really has fantastic bishops it's
guys ok he's got some potential but uh
there's a guy we haven't been focusing
on the King huh so where can I where
should I go like if I could teleport and
this is kind of how you can find it I
mean however you want to think about it
I like to think about just picking it up
and teleporting somewhere I can go
anywhere on this board where would I go
that's sort of the first step and then
you could sort of figure out how do I
get it there so I guess where should
that guy be he actually could be in a
slightly safer spot on the board
I'm gonna open up the queenside why
don't I put him on the kingside exactly
that's what said so that's exactly what
why did he played King - H - yeah
alright it took him he had to use a few
moves to get there but how did you do it
Bishop g2 so yeah a fantastic idea so
yeah again Congrats if you need to come
up with this idea and the idea is run
the King Dage - that's the idea
so I think yeah I'm gonna open it up
eventually but look at this
I just crawl on over I just make my way
over
put the bishop back and well I can't
take it anymore okay let's open it up
let's do stuff on the Kings side and the
Queen side sorry well okay so probably
he should just keep being patient moving
his pieces back and forth not doing
anything but it's hard to not do
anything especially when it looks like
white is making progress you know my
King goes to h2 and he's getting a
little worried so he goes for it b5 but
this isn't entirely correct so whenever
this happens okay now we do really need
to stop here we're like well stuff is
happening now there's some action going
on over there so we need to take our
time and calculate in the game just king
h2 was played which is a fine move
strategically it makes a lot of sense
but wait actually did miss an
opportunity here to get a large
advantage in this position so go ahead
and okay now we there's so much tension
we need to calculate all of these
captures if you know we don't see
anything there or we don't think we
should do anything then King h2 is is
the right move but there actually is
something here it's okay it's
complicated positioned
see pawn takes b5
is the best move yeah good job okay yeah
ken west he just woke up from a coma and
he like it just aren't you already knew
the best move so that was good I know
you you said you were gonna fall asleep
before the lecture and okay I mean if
you just take back routinely why have my
knight and my bishop are on d5 so you
can't really do that perhaps White was
worried about this move okay it seems
sensible and now the rooks are attacking
to c3 but here actually you can play
Knight a for threatening Knight b6 okay
so I suppose I go here and this is
obviously kind of complicated and so
when you've been playing a closed
position for a long time sometimes it's
hard to change back into sort of you
know tactical complicated mode you just
want to keep it you're sort of like I
still want to just make my slow
improving moves but here you actually
have a great move there's one move here
that comes close to winning for white it
might might be you be winning already
but it's it's very close White has a
great move in this position exactly b6
yeah great move okay you go over here
now do be careful because I'm attacking
your knight but uh okay if you just take
this for example your position is just
totally dominating here okay a knight
can come into the game and something
like this is very very good for white
all of the white pieces are about to
come into the game very quickly so this
would just be be crushing black this is
strategically lostalready in this
position
in which in
you know if they're anything Bishop
takes 86 yeah I mean that's yeah this is
not good for black this is he's gonna
collapse very quickly here okay let's
look at what happened in the game so
okay I mean at least some mistakes
remained at this point I do want to I
just want to focus on one more point in
this game okay
so here he took on c4 so you do have to
be kind of careful here as white for
example if you just casually take back
with something well maybe he takes on
before and the rooks come alive she do
have to be careful with which files you
decide to keep open and which ones you
decided to keep closed so he said I
don't want the B file to be open see I
don't want the C file to open up sorry
you know I don't want these rooks
crashing down on my night so I don't
know I'm not gonna take out c4 b5
so temporarily I'm down upon but I I
need to keep the C file closed because
you have two rooks to there and I have
nothing there except for my my little
night in comes the night so I mean I'm
not waiting for you to take my seat
pawns that I'll see if you'll give up my
bishop and really this is not a bad
trade for white at all because well that
night was pretty good and you know the
bishop on f1 I don't know I put a lot of
pawns on light squares so I don't know
he wasn't wasn't so fantastic and
alright coming up soon maybe I'll pick
this guy up so I think here
I think strategically that's just
already uh a great success for white I
think he's been out playing his opponent
and he goes to see for their name to
push the pawn again and he could have
pushed too but this this also is fine
I'm not worried about you taking because
then my Knights come to good squares and
I'm not worried about you bringing my
pieces to good squares yeah exactly yeah
so if the knight does end up getting
here and then there's a lot of pressure
on d6 excellent
I mean and here he played this in the
game b6 is I think the most obvious and
it's just crushing so we won't actually
in the game here happened and I mean
weights weights better here and then
lots of mistakes for me I just want to
talk about one one possibility here in
this position because now okay I'll move
like rook b1 Rho K to be 1 is is okay
that's great great move but there's
actually a surprising tactic so I do
want to see if how alert we've been here
this will be the very last position that
we'll take a look at lots of people I
you know that's I prep these lectures I
just show them to people in the club see
what they come up with and okay this has
been quite a difficult one
hopefully I I give a hint before
somebody actually says it but I'll give
you guys a minute
oh this is actually perfect okay white
to move and the hint is if you were just
walking in the room it's a lot easier to
find this tactic these people have seen
the game so now they have no chance of
finding this but you can do it where
it's probably final view you can do it
you can do it come on these guys have
been here looking at it for minutes you
just walk right in easy and that is the
big hint because well yeah I'll give him
a chance I'll see who wins the audience
or or Owen let's go
Knight to a6 just probably a good move
Knight a5 just like a decent move but I
guess I take on b6 yeah 95 rook b6 oh
you can do it there's 20 people here you
can be a num you can do it it's the rush
who can find it first
yeah oh and nice yeah if you're walking
in the room it's a lot easier because
you haven't seen the last 20-30 moves
all over on the Queen's side now you
didn't say that can hey did you say that
you say a lot of things though we'll
give all the credit to Owen so yes so
this happens all the time - so you're
just doing things on the Queen side for
3040 moves and you just overlooked
something on the King side so this is
how the game of the night singing so you
sick you suggested this move and you use
calculated this and you didn't see the
night okay
all right we'll give all the credit to -
Owen bidding in the audience we're
solving it and and yeah so I mean that's
just again that's the kind of thing that
you can so easily overlook when
everything's happening on one side
forever you stop looking at the other
side but you always want to be vigilant
at all parts of the board so okay I hope
you guys like those puzzles at home if
you like these kinds of lectures let me
know in the comments below and we'll
keep doing some strategical puzzles in
the future
next week we have a very special guest
coming
Mario Roper so hopefully that that goes
through as planned so you guys are good
to see another member profiled here on
the show
so until then hit like share subscribe
and thanks everybody for coming out